quantum break is coming to PC as well as
xbox one and people aren't happy I'm
Kate and this is your gamespot news
update quantum break which was
originally announced as an xbox one
exclusive will also be coming to pc at
launch in April now Microsoft executive
aaron greenberg has defended and
explained this move and also confirmed
more console exclusives are on the way
people should know xbox is a big
priority and a huge commitment he said
please do not let the fact that we are
also launching a game on the same day on
Windows 10 change your perspective on
the importance of the console business
or our commitment to innovating on
console greenberg acknowledged that fans
won't always agree with every decision
Microsoft makes but the company is
committed to trying new things sometimes
we're innovating sometimes we're
experimenting sometimes with charting
new ground on different things he said
we always want to hear people's feedback
we're always listening while they might
not always agree with a hundred percent
of everything we do we love the feedback
greenberg also confirmed that quantum
break will not be available on steam
quantum break on Windows 10 is a Windows
Store exclusive greenberg said everyone
who orders the digital xbox one edition
will also get a free copy of the Windows
10 PC version the console and PC version
supports shared saves although there is
no cross play because quantum break is a
single player game did you buy xbox one
for its exclusives are you frustrated at
Microsoft's decision let me know in the
comments I'll come and find me on
Twitter I'm at how not to draw thanks
for watching and for all your gaming and
entertainment news keep it gamespot
you